Arty's online series epidemic has been
hearing from people who suffered tragic
losses early on on the outbreak when it
was still unclear what exactly was
happening
I want to go home when will you pick me
up those were his last words
I was such a skeptic and had so much
bravado about the coronavirus I was
taking a suburban train to Moscow it was
the last working week I had to deliver
eight movies I have a studio Sasha and I
have a studio we both fell ill as for me
I have the health of an ox
I never feel sick and I don't remember
what a higher temperature looks like but
38 up to 39 degrees Celsius then I
realized that this Cove Atlantean thing
was real
the chief medical officer said he's
taken my husband and his personal
responsibilities everything will be
taken care of of course everything will
be all right as I was approaching the
entry road to Moscow I got a call we've
run out of time he's gone
she will imagine the whole family fellow
my children and I live or lived with my
parents there were five of us together
and both my dad and mom felled wars
simultaneously almost at the same time
unfortunately I had a phone call on the
6th of April and the doctor himself told
me the time and the day of my father's
death and offered his condolences he had
been in hospital for 11 days right
it was his 11th day on a ventilator yes
he passed away in the 6th of April at
8:40 p.m. and I was emotional because of
it I was wondering if you knew about my
mom
[Music]
they just mark their 45th wedding
anniversary this year
I'm so ashamed that until their final
days I kept saying I didn't have health
as strong as my parents my mom for
example could go to the Research
Institute she worked at then go to the
University she was a professor in the
epidemiology department and give a
lecture there then she went home cooked
a meal and did some cleaning and she
picked up her grandchildren to look
after them I couldn't understand how one
person was able to do all that and your
father was a physicist wasn't he yes he
was a famous Russian and Soviet laser
physicist an experimental physicist his
work wasn't just theory
all his discoveries still have practical
use today my parents did a lot and it's
a shame they could have done much more
[Music]
I waited until the very last moment
hoping they would call me and tell me
there had been a mistake it can be true
I said he was really young the new was
so neat and tidy and he understood the
virus was very dangerous
we disinfected everything and we always
sanitized our hands even when we child
from the airport by taxi we disinfected
the car with alcohol I can't understand
how this happened any chronic disease no
nothing at all he had his heart examined
two years ago but he's too young for
heart disease yes just 40 years old did
he have diabetes
no no pre-existing conditions he was an
absolutely healthy young man yes
[Music]
people are like walls that support you
you fear nothing with them worry aside
people whom you can always rely on and
then by the money suddenly one of those
walls crumble solution
I don't know what will happen to me next
you